après un premier confinement la guyane
doit faire face à de nouvelles mesures
pour ralentir la propagation du
coronavirus reparti à la hausse ces
derniers jours tout comme chez son
voisin brésilien le coville 19 a déjà
contaminé près de 5000 personnes et fait
une vingtaine de morts dans la
collectivité française
des chiffres qui risquent de se
multiplier d'ici les prochains jours
la guyane se prépare en effet à un pic
épidémique avant la fin du mois de
juillet face à l'inquiétude
le couvre-feu déjà en vigueur dans la
collectivité a été durci sur tout le
territoire
20 quartiers particulièrement pauvres de
l'île de cayenne ont ainsi été confinés
totalement l'état d'urgence sanitaire a
également été prolongé jusqu'au 30
octobre en guyane par conséquent les
vols entre la région et le reste du
territoire français sont désormais
interdits enfin au coeur des
préoccupations se trouvent aussi les
services hospitaliers
le centre hospitalier de cayenne se
trouve aujourd'hui confrontée à un
afflux de plus en plus important de
patients qui oblige établissements à se
réorganiser au quotidien pour adapter
notamment la quantité de lits en mesure
d'être le meneur des patients candidats
pour pallier à la crise plusieurs
évacuations sanitaires de malades ont
déjà été réalisés vers la guadeloupe et
la martinique
un hôpital de campagne a par ailleurs
été installé au centre hospitalier de
cayenne
son objectif accueillir des patients non
qu'ovide l'installation de cet hôpital
de campagne
dans l'est à côté de l'hôpital va nous
permettre de dédoubler notre service
d'accueil des urgences et donc de le
sécuriser
dans nos urgences actuelles on
accueillera les urgences covin et les
urgences mais l'ont commis seront
accueillis dans l'hôpital de campagne
lorsqu'on va véritablement si sécuriser
les parcours patient
de son côté l'état poursuit son soutien
notamment en aide alimentaire d'urgence
selon la préfecture de guyane 19000 sur
blues 5 respirateur 10000 gants et des
masques ffp2 vont arriver d'ici les
prochains jours une soixantaine de
personnels du ministère de la santé est
aussi attendue ce week end
pas suffisant selon les habitants de
l'île le message principal c'est que
hôpital de campagne
oui mais pas n'importe lequel et par
n'importe quel prix et donc aujourd'hui
ça nous étonne de ne pas entendre parler
de moyens supplémentaires en réanimation
pour pouvoir traiter les 99 c'est de ça
dont on a besoin
l'hôpital est malade en guyane depuis
des années l'état fait l'âne havre
déchets en nous disant qu'ils vont
installer 20 lits pour traiter des noms
d'origine
dans un communiqué l'association
médecins du monde
alerte également à la fois sur la
fragilité du système de santé guyanais
et sur le risque d'une crise sociale
l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
prolongée jusqu'au 30 octobre 2020 en
guyane contrairement à la métropole les
droits sociaux comme l'accès à
l'assurance maladie n'ont pas été
prolongés à nouveau ce qui va constituer
un blocage majeur d'accès aux soins pour
les personnes en situation de précarité
un appel à l'aide
reste à savoir si le gouvernement
français l'entendra